the cause of a dramatic helicopter crash
in the Hudson River near Manhattan is
still a mystery this morning witness
videos show the chopper spinning out of
control and slamming into the water
yesterday afternoon the pilot managed to
escape and is okay
David beg no is near the crash site was
more on what happened David good morning
to you
jail good morning it's raining right now
but the weather was beautiful Sun was
shining tourists were out midtown
Manhattan a lot of people thought the
helicopter pilot was trying to do some
kind of stunt yesterday before the
chopper plunge into the water crowds of
people were watching the helicopter was
clearly in distress
spiraling in the air and then just
dropping from the sky I thought he was I
thought it was like it was like a
private ride or something and he was
like doing some tricks for people the
pilot had just refueled and he was
tempted to leave and reposition a plane
to land again the pilot will suddenly
felt the helicopter calm down the pilot
Erik Morales deployed those yellow
inflatable pontoons to keep the chopper
from sinking a passing ferry picked him
up he was hanging out on the side so we
approached him very slow and we asked
Kenny he was okay the chopper went down
just about a hundred and fifty feet from
the heliport where it was supposed to
land
police say Morales was the only one on
board and he walked away with the cut on
his hand
last year a sightseeing chopper owned by
liberty helicopters crashed into the
East River on the opposite side of
Manhattan that helicopter sank when the
inflatable pontoons did not deploy
properly five people on board died when
they couldn't break free from their
safety harnesses
so the National Transportation Safety
Board is going to investigate what
happened here nor there was substantial
damage to that helicopter but again the
pilot got away with just a cut on his
wrist he is lucky indeed and fortunate
David Pegg no there in the rain thank
you David